we saw this dark black
thing Pats uh
shape in the Seaway
and we knew it wasn't a bird because
birds have got a softer profile and the
next second
um
Bang Bang
the crack was so loud that it hurt our
ears and I believe that was probably the
Keel breaking snapping in half
and then there was a loud splashing
surfing noise behind us and I turned my
head and they were three killer whales
following us
they must have attacked us and Dougal
suddenly appeared
and said get the life raft over the side
and I thought this is for Real it was
just at that moment that I realized this
was for real this was really happening
and we were going to be eaten alive by
these killer whales